le 10 mai 2021 premier jour de
l'opération militaire israélienne
gardien des murailles un missile guidé
israélien saab après d'un ensemble de
quatre maisons à beit hanoun tout au
nord-est de la bande de gaza l'explosion
tué huit civils dont six enfants
cinq jours plus tard une bombe
téléguidée détruit un immeuble de trois
étages situé dans un camp de réfugiés
le camp d'al chati à proximité de gaza
dix personnes sont tuées deux femmes et
huit de leurs enfants tous apparentés le
lendemain 16 mai 2021 c'est un quartier
de gaza cette fois qui est visé
l'objectif selon salle des tunnels et un
centre de commandement souterrains
utilisés par des groupes armés
palestiniens
l'armée israélienne va bombarder le
secteur et plus précisément la rue al
warda une artère commerçante
pendant quatre longues minutes mes deux
filles de 6 et 2 ans dormait quand on a
soudain entendu des normes déflagration
il y en a eu 30 ou 40 du même genre en
l'espace de 5 à 10 minutes toute la
maison s'est mise à trembler mes filles
se sont mis à hurler
cette nuit là on a tous cru qu'on allait
mourir les frappes font s'écrouler trois
immeubles et eu 44 civils 12 hommes 14
femmes et 18 enfants salle évoque des
pertes civiles involontaire mais
l'exécutif israélien lui se félicite de
l'opération dans une opération spéciale
sans précédent nous détruisons
complètement le système de tunnels du
hamas
je dis aux dirigeants des organisations
terroristes
vous ne pouvez pas vous cacher pas au
dessus du sol et pas sous terre
personne n'a d'immunité au total ces
trois frappes israéliennes ont fait 62
morts dont 32 enfants un bilan
particulièrement lourd d'autant que
selon human rights watch
rien ne viendraient étayer la légitimité
de ces bombardements
les forces israéliennes ont mené en mai
des attaques à gaza qui ont décimé des
familles entières alors qu'il n'y avait
pas de cible militaire apparente à
proximité et c'est bien ce qui rendrait
ces attaques parfaitement illégal car
comme le rappellent les ong de défense
des droits humains dans la guerre comme
ailleurs il y à des règles
et ne pas s'attaquer aux civils en fait
partie les attaques dans lesquelles les
dommages prévisible pour les civils et
les biens civils sans commune mesure
avec les avantages militaires espérer
sont également interdites les individus
qui commettent de graves violations des
lois de la guerre avec une intention
criminelle c'est à dire délibérément ou
de manière irresponsable se rendent
responsables de crimes de guerre lo
n'diaye on appelle donc à une enquête de
la cour pénale internationale
de son côté l'armée israélienne se
défend de tout manquement
nous regrettons que human right watch
choisissent de recycler les allégations
déjà réfutées au lieu de condamner les
violations du droit international par le
hamas et d'autres organisations
terroristes
sauf que human rights watch ne s'en est
pas tenue coca israélien selon
l'association 4360 roquettes et obus de
mortier auraient été tirés vers des
centres de population israéliens par des
groupes armés palestiniens roquettes et
obus non guidés et qui frappe sans
discernement civile et militaire ce qui
est parfaitement interdite par le droit
international
un rapport sur les attaques illégales
par des groupes armés palestiniens est
attendu pour le mois d'août
au total selon les nations unies les
attaques israéliennes sur gaza au mois
de mai dernier auront causé la mort de
260 palestine 129 étaient des civils
dont 66 enfants
les roquettes palestiniennes ont elles
tué 12 civils dont deux enfants
autant de familles endeuillées qui
deviendront des ennemis irrémédiable du
camp d'en face
en lisant encore davantage un conflit
dont l'issue pacifique s'éloigne au fil
des morts